dad hmm can I go make an appointment to
see your man doctor was everything okay
yeah yeah it's you're not still worried
about your testicles being two different
sizes are you no I just want to be safe
Oh Alison and I tonight do you know what
time is dinner
Igor you will mommy going with you no
okay just taking care of my my family
hi Igor what brings you in today
well my girlfriend and I have Sai
walking back on the table okay are you
here for condoms yes please
spread your legs are you currently
having sexual intercourse to find
intercourse
have you experienced discharge not now
okay I'm gonna check your chest for
cancer okay now I'm gonna do an invasive
physical exam this is gonna hurt
I need to fill my prescription for a
condom
all right we're condoms really
so do you have insurance you know
that'll be $150 hope it's worth it
granite sex sure oh [ __ ] I forgot to
refill my prescription just go buy more
that's not how it works
I gotta wait 7 days you really need to
be more responsible with the birth
control well maybe you could take
responsibility for the birth control
from now on the baby it won't feel is
good what did you just say you said
you're getting serious it's not even
really no no no no no no no dad oh no no
no no ma ma ma ma ma ma ma ma huh you
want me what are the people at church
find out about this hmm what about that
I can't volunteer anymore now can I